bro hey can I can I show you something
young Jackie Chan
like looks just like Jackie Chan right
no you look just like Jackie my buddy
put me in the old app filter and who's
that you're saying that that looks just
like Jackie Chan bro you look like and
why did you say your uncle cuz my uncle
I look like my uncle I thought you were
going to show me something about your
uncle thought we were going to see what
your uncle my uncle looks like this it
was a really weird setup he looks like
David hwai here he's like you guys would
never believe what my uncle looks like
here's me we all look like Jackie Chan
is the point yeah it was a weird setup
you guys got the Chinese eye that looks
like you right now right now yep that
does look like you smell like that like
a little you also you don't have to
squimp you also relax like this smile
smile look at those Chinese eyes that is
what you do dude yeah